so if you missed it last week there was
this shocking video it appeared from
fulton county georgia
it appeared to show ballot workers
taking boxes of
previously uncounted ballots out from
beneath the table and then counting them
after the room had been cleared
of election observers the voice
narrating that video was jackie diesen
lawyer and host of the jackie daily show
jackie joins us today to talk about that
tape and more importantly the most
damning claims in the election fraud
lawsuit currently happening in georgia
right now
before we jump in this video is
sponsored by ring
jackie thanks so much for joining the
show really appreciate it thanks for
having me ben good to see you
so why don't we start with sort of your
recap of what exactly that tape
was showing so i don't want to
mischaracterize it right so
what i did was narrate the tape for the
georgia state legislature
specifically the senate showing what was
happening at state farm arena
specifically between 10 pm and 1 a.m
on election night we looked there
because we had affidavits from witnesses
who were republican observers who said
there was an announcement that went out
to the press to the the room saying that
counting was done
for the night at 10 30 everyone came
back at 8 30
so everyone left our observers left
frankly they have no legal right to be
present if there's no counting going on
they can't stand guard over the ballots
all night legally
so they left but then they received a
press tip that in fact
counting had continued after they left
so they went back to state farm arena
when they learned this around one
o'clock in the morning
and sure enough the security guard who
wouldn't let them in at first
but finally after some negotiation took
them upstairs
um said yeah the people just left like
five minutes ago
so we went to the tape and sure enough
the tape confirmed exactly what they
told us
so we told the legislature okay so uh
the response from the
georgia secretary of state gabriel
sherling and his office sterling
he suggested that well it appears that
it was true that
perhaps people were told to leave
there's controversy over this from from
state election officials
they they originally said no nobody was
told to leave then they said well maybe
people were told to leave but then there
was a state election monitor who was
present the whole time
uh his statement is that the real
question is about the ballots
themselves so in the video it appears
that there are these boxes of ballots
that are underneath the table
uh you had said suitcases in the
narration they said it was case it
doesn't really matter
there are these boxes of ballots
according to sterling
there were monitors and observers who
were there when these ballots were
originally put into the boxes and
everybody knew the ballots were in the
boxes and everything is on tape anyway
so is the allegation that these ballots
that were then processed were fraudulent
what's the actual allegation about the
the processing of the ballots that were
under the table in the boxes the truth
is no one knows
what those ballots were because even
when our observers were there and the
press were there
they were kept back so far like 40 to
100 feet away
they could not possibly see what those
ballots were this was a continuing
complaint
of the republican party all the way
through early voting
all the way through election day in
counties across georgia we have the
affidavits
our observers were not permitted to even
be where they could see what was going
on
some of the scanners in the room were
behind a wall
they didn't even know they were there
until the spokesperson told them
that evening so the truth is they could
have all been marked for biden
our observers with without binoculars
and without moving their angle
wouldn't know the difference so it's
kind of a worthless meaningless point
because we've been complaining about
this all along
um perhaps yes the ballots were there
are packed in front of them but to us
that holds no meaning
it doesn't change the fact they broke
the law
they cannot count the ballots without
the public being permitted to view the
proceedings
under georgia law you may not mislead
the observers in the presence of leaving
and by the way
cnn abc nbc and the atlanta general
constitution reported
that the spokesperson for the elections
department
told the press that they were sending
everyone home or stopping counting
at 10 30 that night so for the secretary
of state to claim
that no one was told they were going to
stop counting is just
false and even a simple google search
would rebut that also
they said their monitor was there all
the time the monitor
says in a fact check story that in fact
he didn't get there until 11
52 pm that's about an hour and a half
after they announced for everyone to
leave so he says himself
he was not there also about 20 minutes
after he gets there
a deputy chief investigative officer
arrives
from the secretary of state's office why
why would you make an announcement to
the press we're stopping counting at 10
and then send your deputy chief
investigative officer
to state farm marina after midnight i
think it's because
the monitor called him but we don't know
that yet but all of that is suspicious
and the secretary of state's waving his
hands like nothing to see here
that's like you know fact-checking with
him is like
uh asking him to grade his own work
so i mean would there be any way to
verify
the falsity or fraud of the ballots at
this point i mean it sounds as though
it's almost unfalsifiable given the fact
that
that the signatures in my understanding
is in georgia the signatures are
separated from the ballots for purposes
of anonymity typically
and now the signatures have been
separated from the ballots and you can't
match them back up with the ballots they
were with
so unless the numbers didn't match
unless there were fewer signatures than
ballots for example then you'd be able
to tell but if the numbers are the same
then is the allegation that there could
have been substitution or is that
or that the or that the original ballots
has submitted were not legit in the
signature verification
we have several allegations that hit all
points of that but what i would say to
you is
under georgia law what the president has
to show
is not that those people would have
voted for him
uh had they been real ballots or had
they been counted fairly
he only has to show that there were
illegally counted ballots that are
beyond
the margin of victory if we cannot prove
if this wasn't done consistent with law
with our observers observing or the
state monitor observing
we cannot prove that those were legal
ballots they are in question
so is sufficient to overturn the
election we'll jump
right back into this with jackie first i
got to tell you about ring well it is
doorbell season it's that busy time of
year at your front door that means there
are a lot of packages a lot of people at
that front door and for me
i've always wanted to keep an eye on
what's going on in my home plus i have
three kids under the age of seven they
outnumber
me i need to keep an eye on them at all
times this is why i need a ring with
ring
you can keep an eye on all of the hustle
and bustle at your house no matter where
you are directly from
your phone if somebody stops by if
something is going on ring will let you
know you can see and speak to whoever is
there
from anywhere anytime this holiday
season it's not just the best time to
have ring it's a fantastic time to give
it to someone as well
ring makes the perfect holiday gift so
this holiday season gives somebody that
gift of peace of mind
ring has security products for every
corner of your home inside and out best
of all
you can see it all in the ring app when
we removed first thing my wife said is
let's get those ring devices on the
house and thus
we did keep track of my kids that way
keep track of my house that way
ring has everything you need to keep an
eye on your home this holiday season and
throughout the year
see and speak to whoever is at your door
from anywhere with those video doorbells
keep an eye
on every corner of the home with easy to
install indoor and outdoor cams
help protect that whole home with ring
alarm powerful affordable whole home
security system
you can easily install yourself so for a
limited time head on over to ring.com
ben for special holiday offers again
that's ring.com ben
the the allegations that are made about
this particular tape i know that there
is one outstanding georgia lawsuit
uh it was originally filed last week uh
late friday
not the cracking sydney powell lawsuit
which was dismissed uh but the the one
that was that was filed
on friday um by rudy giuliani and the
actual trump legal team
uh they had forgotten to pay some sort
of filing fee they refiled it uh as of
as of yesterday
and it's now under consideration is all
of this included in that lawsuit
um all of it is included in this suit
and actually the scent was going forward
before we had the video um based on very
cut-and-dried points such as about 2500
felons voted
about 66 000 underage people voted
about 5 000 voters voted who had left
georgia
and registered in another state under
georgia law
that means you're automatically
disqualified from voting
and so much more i would say over 100
000 people
are listed here who illegally voted who
should not have voted
and that's all the president has to show
to either get a new election
or to certify the current one so i have
those votes actually been
been tabulated meaning that when we look
at the final voter account that has been
certified by the state of georgia
and they've now done i believe three
recounts of the votes the the numbers
that you're mentioning those are
included in that final voter accounts is
the allegation
correct okay so um what is the state of
georgia's response to
all of this and what's the defense been
because if you can name the voters who
are voting fraudulently and it should be
pretty easy to substantiate
people who are registered out of state
voting in the election or people who are
underage but i mean we know when people
are born
uh so so what has their response been
so far they haven't responded because we
just filed it friday night
so let's see what happens we'll find out
soon because we'll have an expedited
process because we have to
so we'll given the circumstances so what
is the timeline on this particular
lawsuit because
uh even folks who have been you know
fairly staunchly
defensive of the georgia electoral
system folks like eric erickson down in
georgia
uh even he has said this is easily the
most uh well-predicated lawsuit that he
has seen filed
at this point and it is worthy of note
that you know the the veracity of this
lawsuit has nothing to do with whatever
is going on in pennsylvania or
arizona uh and it may not even turn the
election more broadly given the fact
that trump would actually have to win
georgia and arizona and pennsylvania
uh in order to in order to win the
election so when we're talking about
this lawsuit we're just talking about
proper ballots being counted in improper
balance not being counted so everybody
should be on the side
of that what is the path forward for the
lawsuit what's the timeline given the
safe harbor provisions and law
i think it's difficult to say the judge
has the discretion to expedite
the process which we think is almost
certain um i'm told the secretary of
state has waived
excuse me his five days that he has to
respond
normally he gets five days automatically
because he's the state so
i'm not sure what's going to happen here
and how quickly it can move
it might be advantageous for a judge to
sit still
until the time has passed the december
14 deadline even then
it's the opinion of our lawyers it's
still alive
we want to litigate to the truth no
matter what because the relief
asked for in the petition is not just
about the election
it's about forcing the secretary of
state to do his
job and get all of these illegal people
off the rolls
first of all i and that would be in time
for the senate elections by the way
getting these people off the rolls that
would be super valuable
right away because you see how close the
senate was in the in the first
go around and so again i think that it's
it's important to recognize that that a
well-predicated lawsuit is worthwhile
here
uh regardless of of your political
opinions about the outcome
of the election i mean everybody should
be on board with if voter fraud and
voter regularity are shown
the state doing its job why do you think
it is you know obviously
yeah there's been a lot of conspiracy
theories that have been put out there i
i'm not a conspiracy theorist and don't
tend to believe in them
uh about you know brian kemp and
raffensberger the georgia secretary of
state
you know being uh somehow you know
bought and paid for i don't tend to
believe that stuff what do you think is
the motivation here is it just that
they're defensive
of the georgia legal system have they
not been shown the evidence
what do you think is the hold up here i
don't you don't need to go as far as to
say there's a conspiracy
or something you know an international
payoff or something like that
really it might be as simple as
they are politicians just like the
people in dc who when they fall under
pressure from people like stacy abrams
and the democrat party
capitulate in a settlement agreement
earlier in the year
that losing the standards for absentee
ballots which is where most of the fraud
is
and now they have to own what happened
they don't want to have to own that
georgians votes
the georgian election might have been
stolen under their watch
i think it's as simple as that they
don't want to take accountability for
their actions
or inaction and so final final question
for you jackie diesen
she is of course the former counsel to
the chairman of the u.s house
subcommittee on the constitution and
she's a senior fellow at the texas
public policy
foundation uh so final question there's
been a lot of talk
uh in republican circles about
republicans boycotting the senate
elections in january i cannot think of
something
possibly more counterproductive i just
wanted to get your opinion
uh on that piece of inanity nothing
could be worse
than the republicans stay home that
guarantees a win
for the democrats for the two senate
races i have no idea
why anyone would recommend that step
even though it's true there are
irregularities
this is a loosey-goosey process you do
have a secretary of state who's not
doing his job in my opinion
and i think we've proved that i
understand but you don't protest that
by throwing away the u.s senate you
achieve nothing so please
georgians show up to vote show up to
vote despite the imperfections
you know we have to show up and fight
for that senate
no compromises jackie thanks again for
joining me if you want to hear more from
jackie diesen check out her show the
jackie daily show it's available
wherever you listen to podcasts
thank you ben so what do you guys think
is this the supposed kraken is this
going to have any effect on the georgia
election results let me know what you
think in the comments down below